the complexity of somewhat approximation
so
so madhur will talk next and his result
is a
slightly more complicated so i thought
that i would present this smaller cuter
result first
so the main statement of the result is
on that board
it's just a dichotomy theorem for csps
in the morning suon presented his
result on csps and he talked about
approximation resistance
so i will give some context to those
results and
and
and i will present my results along with
the context
so this is how the talk should go uh
i will present the conditional version
where we assume
p not equal to np then the unconditional
hardness which is
what these hierarchy results are the
laser and these sorts of things and then
i will give an overview of the proof in
the paper this last section i will
probably skip
because
it's just a proof in the paper which we
probably won't have time
and
the paper is on eccc
yeah so
as many of you are familiar with kcsps
you know that they are quite popular in
theory and
they are
mentioned in several academic contexts
uh most prominent being schaefer who
who proved dichotomy theorems for
kcsps and
we want to emulate the result of
schiffer for
the case when the csp we don't want to
decide the satisfiability of the csp but
we want to decide the
optimum value of a max kcsp instance for
a given predicate f
and
the problem of finding
max kcsp
is of course np complete and
the instance is so this is essentially
the problem
fi are constants
constraints derived from the initial
predicate f
alpha is just an assignment on the n
variables there are m constraints and
you want to optimize this sum
which is the expected value of your csp
now
it is obvious so let us call row f as
the density of the predicate f which is
just the number of satisfying
assignments of f divided by 2 to the k
and we restrict ourselves to the boolean
setting because
in the higher alphabet setting things
are going to be much more complicated
now we choose a uniform random
assignment and it will satisfy row a
fraction of constraints so this is a row
f approximation algorithm and
we want to see if we can do better than
this trivial algorithm
and
start proved that it is hard for xor
so his result is just stated here that
it is hard to distinguish between 1
minus epsilon versus rho f minus epsilon
predicates
and
such predicates are known as
approximation resistant predicates so
you can't beat the random assignment
so what about so this leads to a natural
question what about predicates other
than xor
and
so f is said to be a support a
probability distribution mu
if so and so condition is satisfied and
a linear predicate l corresponds to
assignments l inverse one which form a
points of space of f two
and
k zero is a linear predicate
and
so now we generalize linear predicates
into what is known as well distributed
linear predicates
which which are predicates which are
linear predicates which support
pairwise independent distributions on
the assignments
mu
now
as seon said kxr is a linear predicate
and it's also well distributed linear
predicate
and
this is his result stated in this
notation that for k greater than equals
epsilon positive
l a well distributed linear predicate
then l is approximation resistance this
we saw today morning
and
the general question is
which nonlinear predicates are hard to
approximate assuming p naught equals and
p
so
so let us ask let us define a weaker
notion
which we call tau resistance instead of
approximation resistance
and while approximation resistance asked
for one versus row gaps we ask for tau
versus row gaps
and
we will address this original
we will address this weak version of our
original question
so
essentially our question is to
characterize tau f minus rho of f
for a given predicate f
and
so that's approximation resistance in
the top and this is tau resistance
and as a star already investigated tau
resistance
he introduced somewhat approximation
resistance where
he studied predicates which are
tau resistance for any tau greater than
rho of f
and
tau resistance is just a more precise
terminology
and we are able to characterize tau f
minus rho of f up to a factor of k to
the 5.
if you just go over the
statement of the theorem it will be
clear that tau f minus rho of f is
completely characterized but
but
we will come to this
so let q be the set of quadratic
predicates uh
that means predicates with no fourier
mass at level three or above
this is an example
and
and these two are the results of a star
that if q if f is
not in q then f is resistant
somewhat approximation resistant and if
f is in q then it is not even somewhat
approximation resistant
and the algorithm for this we will
actually our our algorithm for tau
resistance will actually build on this
algorithm
yes so this is the main theorem
and
so so in the first case we just say that
if f is bounded if f is far from q the
class of quadratic predicates
uh if it is so far then
tau f we show to be we lower bound tau f
to be greater than equal to rho of f
plus 1 over k to the 5
otherwise f is close to some quadratic
and
let us call that quadratic g
so if
g monotonically dominates f then we
actually give an algorithm we upper
bound tau f
but
if no if the g does not monotonically
dominate f then we again give a lower
bound for tau of f so these are the
three cases uh
so what is striking about this
result so
to derive to prove our three cases uh
the proofs are not very complicated uh
they are pretty simple but uh
but
but this statement is very simple and
there are no such simple dichotomy
statements uh very few i mean what we
saw previously a start statement was one
but
there are other dichotomy results
and
for example there is one with austrian
and code for
apartheid csps
and
they are very complicated statements
madhur will present one which is also a
very complicated statement but this
statement it's very intuitive and
and this is sort of
the gold standard which one could hope
for to prove for
i mean for approximation resistance so
so you would want such an intuitive
classification of all approximation
resistant predicates
so
okay so this k greater than equal to k
naught so k naught is some constant it's
pretty large in our proof it's like
double exponential but uh
i think it's an artifact of the proof
technique here because we rely on this
fried good jantar hunter theorem for
some cases that's why it grows double
exponential but
it's just an artifact and probably with
a different proof technique
it will probably be just exponential but
but yeah so we we are dealing with csps
of largerity we should always keep that
in mind when we
is that okay
oh this k factor yeah so so so
so
in all of these cases
you should think of the statement as
characterizing the gap tau f minus rho
of f
yeah so
so
and this tau f minus rho of f is within
k to the five now why i get k cube and
why i get k
that's because in every k
in each case the proof method is
completely different that's why all
these key factors are different
you will see
yeah so essentially this is a summary of
whatever i thought was relevant this is
the past what was known as far as
somewhat resistance is concerned and
this is what
this paper shows
ok so let me just
say something about unconditional
hardness because
i think it is at least as important as
conditional hardness so here we don't
assume p naught equals np
and we work with weak models of
computation
and
we use these stp and lp irr keys as our
model because
these algorithms so so any model is
interesting if you can get non trivial
algorithms from it
and
both lp and sdp hierarchies give
non-trivial algorithms for max kcsps for
some predicates
so there are results by haast
and so on which and there is one by
travis sun for example
which
which actually beats the random
assignment for some predicates for some
sparse predicates
and
and that's why
lp and sdp hierarchies are a good model
to study
and
lower bounds against surrounding
algorithms are important
in this setting also you can you can
study the hierarchy of lesser which is
the strongest sdp hierarchy
and
you can define approximation resistances
as
getting gaps of one versus row and
if you fail for lesser you could
substitute weaker hierarchies like ls
plus
so
for example in this setting the
counterpart to hasta's result is this
result by shonabek which is
which shows that max k xor is
approximation resistance where it's this
now approximation resistance is defined
in this sense
and
and then the counterpart to chance
result is the result by madhur which
shows well distributed linear predicates
are approximation resistant
and
this result was already known in 2009
while chance result is much more recent
i don't know if this inspired that or
what but
so
and now you can ask the same question
which non-linear predicates are hard
and let me just say that
not only can you substitute weak
hierarchies like ls plus in particular
you could substitute any proof system
you wanted and you could study these
dichotomy theorems and people have done
they haven't studied dichotomy theorems
but they have studied hardness of
predicates in proof complexity
okay so now
just like tau resistance we have tau
star resistance where you work with this
lesser hierarchy
linear rounds and
and one resistance is what
and the main theorem here for tau star
resistance is exactly similar to the
theorem with assuming p naught equals
and p
which is nice because
we had to do very little work to get the
same result
and
this is what is known as far as lesser
hierarchy was concerned and
this is what we prove
okay so
uh now i will concentrate on this uh p
not equal assuming p naught equal to np
the conditional hardness result and uh
and
but
the results generalized to the lesser
in the same manner i mean the techniques
don't really change a lot
so
so roughly as i mentioned that
charm and madhu's result is just that
well distributed linear predicates are
hard
and
let us call good predicates as those
well distributed linear predicates which
have very few accepting assignments
so the sparse well distributed linear
predicates are good predicates for us
and
so if the accepting assignments
correspond to the hard mode code
they are then l is a good predicate
and if it corresponds to the hamming
code it's not good
and now
we want to translate known results about
good predicates to weak results about
all predicates
so for this we introduce the notion of
tau correlation which just says
whatever is given this is the definition
which which essentially means that the
accepting assignments of f and l
essentially coincide to a large degree
so let's start so in the first step uh
what we show is if f is tau correlated
to a good predicate then f is also tau
resistant
and the idea is simply a reduction from
phi l
uh we construct an instance phi f such
that uh
if phi l was greater than one minus
epsilon then
phi f is tau minus at least
the val refers to the value of the max k
csp of course
and
no case also
and
and
from phi l we obtain phi f and some
calculations some very simple
calculation show that
tau correlation implies uh
tau resistance
and this is the summary of the last
slide
so our next goal would be to
characterize uh what is the best
possible correlation you can have for a
given f with
with some good predicate
and
yeah so
so this is
it could even be k for the right values
of k you just take the hadamard code and
slide it and you will get 1 over k
correlation but we need better values
when rho f is a constant c
when i say constant
please note k here
is not held to be a constant
when i say constant i mean absolute
constants
so
so now we will go towards our goal which
is to characterize the best possible
correlation of f with some good
predicate
and
let us define gamma r as the fourier
mass above level r
so step 2 we show that rho f is greater
than gamma 3 f over k square
and this proof
is by probabilistic argument which is
the proof in the last section which i
will not present
but
eventually we will find that working
with gamma is a bit cumbersome so so we
will prove
so we proved this as a lemma in the
paper and this is step two so tau f will
be greater than rho of f plus omega of
comma three f over k square where gamma
is the fourier mass of level 3
but for cases 2 and 3
in the main theorem we will need to work
with delta because working with gamma
becomes cumbersome so
we need to relate gamma to delta in
particular gamma 3
and here is where we lose
i mean we show this result that gamma 3
f is related to delta
within a constant factor
recall that q is the set of quadratics
and
the claim is similar to the theorem of
fright good kali and now
which which deals with gamma 2f and
our proof of this fact used
just the theorem of fried good
and we thought it was new but
apparently this result is also known
from a paper of kindler and safra an
unpublished paper of kindler and safra i
mean
it's not stated in this way there but
but a look at that proof essentially
convinces us
that
it follows easily from the result
and
so steps one two and three together
prove
tau f greater than
equals rho of f plus one over k to the
five
essentially and
all that remains is case 2 and case 3.
so case 2 is a lower bound and case 3 is
actually an algorithm
in the unconditional setting we would
get tau star greater than this u from
the same steps
so
in step four which is the case two of
the theorem
we we want to lower bound tau f as rho f
plus 1 over k
and
this proof
is a bit technical it's essentially a
reduction using well distributed linear
predicates and
and it's just
a bunch of calculations which are quite
simple but i will not
give the calculations in this talk
i defer to the paper
but essentially this reduction from
directly from chan's result is enough to
prove
tau f greater than equals rho of f and
one thing
about this case is that
even though gamma 3 f is small we are
able to lower bound tau by
rho f plus 1 over k
which means that gamma 3 f is not enough
to characterize tau of f completely
and finally the algorithm
which means the upper bound for tau of f
so we are given
ah rho f plus epsilon satisfiable
instance
and
and
the sdp rounding algorithm which is
based on the algorithm of chariqar
inverts
will output a rho f plus
c epsilon over k square satisfiable
assignment
and
which means of course that
tau f has to be less than or equal to
this
so
so the result of charity current what it
gives rho of f plus c epsilon
essentially
when you know that
your csp is rho f plus epsilon
satisfiable
and
so that should be g not f
and now we substitute
so now here is a simple algorithm we
substitute g for f in our max k csp
instance uh use the algorithm of
chariqar and worth
then whatever assignment it outputs you
want to take that assignment and
use it as your assignment for max kcspf
the only problem is that
remember that now g monotonically
dominates f so
which is the last case and so
what may happen is uh
the algorithm may output some assignment
which does badly on every constraint in
the csp
and
while max kcspg may have a high value
max k cspf has a
much lower value
we can we can correct this what we do is
we introduce an extra step behind the
chariqar worth algorithm so whatever
assignment
charlie current worth output
what we do is we
we take it as an advice set and with a
small probability we take that advice
and with a large probability
1 minus 1 over 2 k we flip the
assignment in a random fashion zero and
one with equal probability and this
correction actually works
and the proof is uh not very difficult
it is again just an analysis of the
expression of the expectation
and
you will get
you will get this after a little bit of
calculations which again i differ to the
paper
so this finishes the outline of the main
theorem
and i will stop here
if there are open
i mean the open question is obvious uh
characterize tau as best as possible for
constant values instead of values
depending on the arity
thank you
questions or comments
break until 3 40
and then
we'll have the talk that was tended to
be now but we will sort of be
we thought this order was better okay
thanks again
thank you